a Navy SEAL described as a serial killer
by some was pardoned by Donald Trump
and he is capitalizing on his newfound
fame which came from being pardoned for
horrible crimes by becoming a right-wing
influencer Hawking all sorts of
different products this is the story of
Eddie Gallagher Eddie Gallagher was a
Navy SEAL chief petty officer he posed
with the body of a dead Iraqi child
while in Iraq he allegedly committed
multiple war crimes including killing a
fifteen-year-old
ultimately he was acquitted of
everything other than posting a picture
with the dead kid and Donald Trump
granted him clemency in November and
this became a big thing and this has
turned Eddie Gallagher into an
influencer for salty frog gear he now
sells t-shirts and supplements much in
the style of conspiracy theorists Alex
Jones he's selling coffee beans he's
selling muscle builders things that have
a kill bad dudes logo on them this guy
is being celebrated by the American
right for what for what they have a
shirt that says waterboarding instructor
making money bragging about torture that
is part of the disgusting and dark
history of what the United States has
done overseas his fellow Navy SEALs have
said this guy's quote toxic quote
freakin evil and a murderer who quote
wants to kill anybody he can Trump has
called Gallagher quote one of the
ultimate fighters I think the New York
Times probably deserves some credit here
as well they did a profile of this guy
and all of the products that he's
promoting without even really talking
about the guy's past if you want to
critique the horrors of Donald Trump
granting him clemency and the guy
becoming a right-wing darling that's an
interesting article I would like to see
the New York Times profile is more like
you know they're talking about this guy
like he's an entrepreneur like how
innovative that he was able to turn a
pardon for war crimes into selling
supplements and the scariest part of it
all is that the right seems to be
responding to him positively as an
influencer and the only things this guy
could influence people to do in my mind
are all bad
things that we don't want anybody doing
these are people who have had listen if
you look at other people who have done
horrible things and have had their
careers rehabilitated my mind when I was
thinking about this yesterday
particularly because we're talking about
Iran now my mind went to Oliver North
and my mind went to G gordon Liddy our
younger viewers and listeners may not
know these names Oliver North was
convicted in the iran-contra affair and
then he later ran for office his image
was totally rehabilitated he was in TV
on TV all the time I actually got an
email from someone saying Ollie North
was on Fox News last night talking about
Iran can you imagine although I didn't
see that if it's not true apologies in
advance gee gordon liddy was convicted
of conspiracy burglary and illegal
wiretapping for his role in the
watergate scandal he later got a radio
show which he may still have I haven't
done not really pay too much in the
radio game he may still have that but
really none of this should surprise us
at this point because people who have
done really horrible things have had
their careers rehabilitated and
sometimes we may be okay with it
sometimes we may not but this is a guy
who is known only for having war crimes
pardoned by the President of the United
States and it is immediately becoming at
least somewhat lucrative for him we
don't really know how much truly
sickening and disgusting